the stadiums of the first world cup in
the middle east are architectural
mirrors of arab culture and heritage
a tent used by bedouins
an ivory cap worn by pious muslim boys
and men
a gold-colored handicraft
we've invested a lot during the design
stage prior to the construction to make
sure that whatever is being built for
the for the tournament is being kept for
the legacy and the local
needs and even the local league needs
welcome to lucille stadium
home to the final match and the closing
ceremony
up to 86 thousand fans will enjoy
unobstructed views of the field
the roof contains one and a half times
the amount of steel as the eiffel tower
in terms of
an experience
purely from a sporting point of view it
will be unprecedented and really
spectacular i can't emphasize that word
enough
stadium 974 is the first venue in fifa
history that will disappear
the 974 recycled shipping containers
will be dismantled to give way to
additional waterfront development after
the world cup
the beauty of this stadium is that
it will have many more
opening games in different countries and
different cultures
and in different locations but also
become i think
the first stage in the world which which
has this overpowering sustainability
statement to it
in addition to stadium 974
seats and components of other venues
will be donated to developing countries
in need of sport infrastructure but the
non-profit group carbon market watch
says to offset emissions the material
would need to be used multiple times
especially if shipped thousands of
kilometers away
by using recycled materials reducing
construction costs and developing green
and living spaces near stadiums qatar is
hoping it created monuments to
sustainability that will inspire future
world cup hosts
natasha name al jazeera doha